hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians
are classy individuals or absolute
trash now here are your hosts
kevin ryan and h foley
baby hey everybody out there and welcome
back to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is
r u garbage the show where we sit down
with your favorite comedians
and find if they grow up classy or if
they're absolute trash i'm your host
stage foley coming at you on a beautiful
day here in the east village of
manhattan
here at gas digital networks gas digital
studios
the big [ __ ] studio my co-host coming
at you
from right next to me he's my best buddy
in the whole world and if i don't tell
you enough
i love you kids gang give me away makes
me feel weird the next time you're
reaching for a best pal you go ahead and
make it a kippy
and now with the holiday season the
halloween season you can get them in a
fun size
ladies and gentlemen kevin james ryan
unfortunately on fun size
all year round happy to be here thanks
for tuning in
i talked to my wife not the kid over
here the kids got a hog
um guys make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube this one's already goofy
full video available on youtube and you
can sign up for gas digital network you
get all the
all the perks from the network if you
use promo code ayg you save a couple of
bucks
we make a couple of bucks we get to win
our beak at the end of the month
love that money win for everybody
check it out very nice gang we cannot be
more excited to have our very special
guest here with us today
i am rock hard i'm gonna say that right
now
i feel like he is the opposite of
everything that i am he's tall he's
attracted
this is this has been one people
requested like you gotta get him
on gillis kfc they've all been like
cause
he's he's gonna throw you through a loop
so we're not sure when he seems like
he's got a bit of an attitude too and i
kind of like that
he would not talk to me at a country
club i know that yeah because i was
in tables if i was if i was waiting
tables for him he would not make eye
contact
and i respect i respect that there's
just
there's really no country club i would
join that
would hire you i i don't know what else
to say that kid's hot
i just don't see working exactly
somewhere that i belong to
i i don't if they did hire you he would
switch places
for sure ladies and gentlemen he's a
very funny stand-up comedian actor and a
writer all right he is the host of oops
the podcast he has his very own comedy
special out
right now called bad guy he's a [ __ ]
tall drink of water let me tell you this
guy's an avenger
give it up for francis ellis everybody
you holy crap you have to be there's no
way this guy's garbage
nah he's clay you're class throwing
through oh i've got some skeletons well
maybe you and your fraternity brothers
killed a homeless guy once but i don't
even know if
i would call that garbage time yeah it's
just rich kids being rich kids yeah we
didn't have fraternities at
at my school where did you go to school
i went to harvard
[Laughter]
satellite or maine was it harvard
altoona what one was it yeah it was
their primary yeah
not an offshoot you went to harvard i
did yeah
oh would you study at harvard who killed
kennedy
i studied uh government with a focus on
the middle east
wow yeah last he could be
could be an agent i that's what i wanted
to do
really originally yeah in operations
applying to nsa and the cia wow didn't
hear back
really maybe i missed it that's the
thing it could have been like i i
didn't read the soot in the chimney you
know what i mean yeah
i think they sound like a writing packet
a couple of monologue jokes
three desk pieces hired by the cia
yeah what's that application like it's
really long and it's it's
it's a little intense because they ask
you things like
and i i do sort of a bit about it but
they ask you you know have you ever done
any illegal
narcotics and then they remind you at
the bottom of the page
that all your answers can be verified
via polygraph test that they're going to
confirm
everything you've you have to you know
and you're like whoa this is
that's a lot yeah i bet they wouldn't
care if you smoked a little dooby
they want you to have a little street
smarts yeah by that time i was a little
deeper
there wasn't a little doobie here no it
wasn't it was a little colombian
i wasn't experimenting i was doing at
this point all right so now we got a
little checkered past i like to hear
that
good looking end damage that's what i'm
going for
um holy [ __ ] harvard you were a lacrosse
player too
yeah all american or something in high
school as an all-american
these kids this kid comes from good
[ __ ] stock did you play lacrosse at
harvard i did holy [ __ ] full scholarship
so the ivy's donald trump scouts
athletic scholarships they do need based
only
where were you offered scholarships uh
well i
i had a few um i wouldn't say they were
like scholarship offers
because you don't get i don't think you
get a scholarship offer
until you've like said yeah i wanted to
come to you
okay but i i was recruiting you uh
a lot of duke johns hopkins yeah he says
that
albany you brag about widener university
yeah i played a little division three
lacrosse
nice nice yeah let's see what's wrong
with that see how
nice no that's good you're good looking
good [ __ ] that's what that was hey fatty
go get yourself a candy bar
well i went to this camp there was a
camp my junior summer called the nike
blue
back then it was the graftex blue chip
camp he sounds like illuminati doesn't
he
that's what tim dillon says he texted me
and asked me like when my grandparents
are taking over
stuff like that but uh there was this
camp and it was the top hundred players
in the country
and uh i went to that i got invited to
go to that and then
i was one of the people that had like
slightly better
sat scores and all the coaches have
their little uh
they had their folder on you and when
they see you out in the field
wearing the number they look up the
number like i like this kid they look
him up they got your height and your
weight
ratchet and then your grade point
average and your
sat scores and all that right there and
they're like well i can i can either
continue to look at this kid or not
and like you know brown and harvard and
princeton have to basically close the
book on a lot of
kids sure but for me they were like oh
you know
we can work with that nice we're going
to ask you anyway but we might as well
ask you now
what did you get on the sats i took the
i took the ones that were
three sections okay do you guys remember
that yeah that switched after so how old
are you like thirty
thirty one okay yeah so switch right
after me i'm 34. okay yeah so you were
like one of the last i was one of the
last years to have the
1600 but now it's back to 616. they
moved back to 16.
yours is out of what 26. that was a 2400
so what'd you get uh i got a i think a
2280
dude that's three times what you got on
the one out of 1600 who is this [ __ ]
guy
yeah i don't know i mean i ended up that
was i tutored the sat
when i moved to new york and was doing
stand-up for the first like five six
years i was here so that was
that was my gift that's a pretty good
gig yeah good decent hours good cash
i i knew a kid that was a comic he was
real book smart too but like his day job
was
so much more like refund like i'm you
know i'm waiting tables busting tables
he was doing that he was like teaching
kids like lsat yeah
that's a whole new ball game i did i
took the lsat
but uh it was way harder why'd you take
the lsat
i thought i had a free day after two
years of stand-up
and being in the mics which were getting
drearier and drearier i just was like
i've given it a shot
this is crushing me and i thought i
needed to get real
so i decided i should go to law school i
went for four days
and with drew because i was like this
isn't what i want at all
and then i doubled down on tutoring and
and comedy and that's when things
started actually
getting a little better you must have
been going around the new york open mics
looking around at those people like
they're [ __ ] mutants dude
you you guys know i mean it was it was a
it was a
a race to the bottom oh man every night
you press it you come in and it was the
you're only performing for other
comedians so it's a contest to see who
can
tell the saddest story yeah and if you
get up
first of all i would get up and and
everyone [ __ ] hated me
right away right up right from the jump
happy and the antithesis
of everybody at the new york comedy open
mind and so then all these comics if i
ever went like early in the show which
was
rare because i couldn't get there in
time to sign up early
i would go towards the you know if i
were one early every comic after me
would just talk about me that [ __ ]
guy is talking about whatever and
it would be like [ __ ] over like four
comics later and you're like
we're still on this you know what's
happening that's why they're
still all in those basements a lot of
those guys never hey that's the price of
beauty buddy i don't know
a lot of sounds never get out i sound
like an [ __ ] but
it's true yeah just like how many you
know nazi youth jokes can you hear
you know it was always the same [ __ ]
yeah what was the situation growing up
humble beginnings well my my parents
were from new jersey originally
that's where i lived until i was four
okay like atlantic highlands area which
isn't too far from here i don't know
that sounds
expensive okay i know middletown
highlands uh yeah
i was in the i was in the norristown
lowlands
flood region below sea level
sounds like a place that the gnomes
abide
it's like it's a middle-earth tear his
house was just a door and a hill
a lot of mist yeah a lot of doing
a lot of doors with big knockers on them
fog in the evenings
built into hillsides hello sir
so gentlemen i we that's where we moved
to maine when i was four
main and i grew up we're at maine
freeport maine
okay close to portland it's like 20
minutes north yeah so
down down east they call it and what did
your parents do what was that situation
uh my dad moved to maine and started a
small software company up there
okay when i was four
[Laughter]
no he he started it uh he had met a
programmer that had an idea and he
thought my dad thought he could kind of
conceptualize and build off this idea
but the programmer was the guy who had
gone to the university of maine
uh you know they have a engineering
school he'd gone there and
okay uh it was it was a software company
that was going to connect
i don't mean to get boring but like no
what do you mean i want to hear this to
be honest with you
i don't really know exactly what he was
trying to get out he's like there's a
thing with the rats oh it's all ones and
zeros really if you think about it
to the cia point my dad traveled a lot
when i was a kid and i could never
really understood what it was that he
did
there was a serious time in my youth
where i actually just
assumed he was in the cia and i'm dead
serious about that's like good shepherd
kind of [ __ ] and i wouldn't ask him
there was never you could have never
mistaken my dad doing this
strip club maybe but not a cia
county jail out of al-qaeda down at
knicks roads beef i think
what'd your dad actually do my dad owned
a mechanical contracting company
he made my dad my dad made a very good
living um lost it a couple of times but
there was there was money growing up
yeah redemption story i like that yeah
i think he's down now but i'm but i'm
trying to get to like what did what did
your dad's dad do like there has to be a
lineage here
i mean you know it's it's weird dude i
would i would say this
uh there's no way this dna well this is
what
this is what we were actually just
talking about last episode with jeff
like there's my
my family got money first generation got
money and they're
sacrifices they don't know how to spend
it they still do it like
as you have it for generations you
become more and more refined and that's
what you look
more refined yeah but but retaining
wealth
yeah over generations is very very
difficult it's that saying of like
a rich guy thing to say right there
retaining it's like the patriarch
you know starts the company his son
builds
and then the third generation spends it
[ __ ] blows it all
is what i've heard my family it's gonna
sound ridiculous and and i
i want you to bear with me on this we're
in baby so
my my mom's dad my mom went to princeton
but she was in the first class of women
at princeton
and had to just basically get sexually
harassed i mean sexually harassed tough
on a level where you're like even even
cringeworthy
doing a bit you wouldn't even be like
ooh i don't you couldn't bend to be like
that's
funny she had a rough time yeah
but crushed it and was whatever did well
and then
her dad went to princeton his dad went
to princeton it was six
direct generations wow at princeton
and then uh my sister went to yale okay
but she was a lacrosse player too so she
was also recruited and that and that
just
helps it makes it a lot easier to get
into these schools
yeah and then uh my dad went to amherst
college which is like a little
liberal arts school in in massachusetts
right
but but you know his dad ran out like a
plant a plant an industrial plant in new
jersey
okay uh didn't really do that well my
dad started this new company
it didn't do well for 15 years okay and
then it started doing well and then he
sold it like
five years ago all right so you guys
weren't rich like growing up
we were fine i hate to say that i hate
to say this i would say upper middle
class yeah
okay i hate to say that because i know
it's such a douchey [ __ ]
especially [ __ ] great it's about time
we got a little [ __ ] class
well i'm sitting right here what are you
talking about not talking about your
dad's joint fitter money this guy's
sixth generation he was skimming off the
top sixth generation's princeton
his mom went to school with [ __ ] john
nash what are you talking about you know
who she was roommates with
who uh lisa hallaby who was he's
dropping he's dropping rich guy names on
him
is that the broad that lived down on
third street
she became she married the guy they
don't do one of the voices for rick and
morty jordan
yeah oh my god i know who you're talking
about see i knew you would there you go
foley i've seen her in the people
magazine she's stunning she's stunning
she's
out yeah so queen nor she became queen
noor of jordan
you guys ever get the hookup to go over
there spend the night at the pat at the
castle
so she's my sister's godmother what the
[ __ ]
well my mom was like talking about your
hvac money do me a favor go go check out
the cars
we still have some of the local unions a
little bit of cash
shout out to 690 guys going to the
presidential palace in jordan
that's right and i think it's an acaba
is the name of the city god bless you
yeah it's come it's lovely in the fall i
never went to jordan
but i went to their house in england
they have like an essay
in england an apartment or like what is
it it's huge okay sprawling not a flat
yeah
horses damn no roommates i would imagine
they do they do
did the prop like those castles and [ __ ]
like those estates and [ __ ]
in england yeah are [ __ ] they were
that's all they really do it well yeah
sure
damn pretty classy i think they airbnb
that thing
let's get into a little are you garbage
so we're thinking so we're looking at
upper middle class
in maine yeah um i guess we'll lead off
i got one that we were just talking
about at what age this is a big one this
is
i obviously you are not guard let's this
that's impossible i want to see if i can
sell you that i am
i excellent i love it i don't think deep
seated
okay uh nefarious drug history problems
in my
core oh i like it the way he just said
that made me
[ __ ] shake riddled with poison oh he
could be so he could go
psycho easy yeah he's gotta get the list
guys kill them
oh baby um at what age did you get your
passport
a great question because he doesn't have
one and he's 45 years old so there ain't
nothing i need out there i can't get
in the good old u.s survey but you know
you know classy kid i got mine pretty
young but like i had friends that were
like you know 11 with a passport or
something like jesus yeah they go to
like the dr
they were traveling what about you i
mean i would have been or i would have
been like
probably like six maybe even five what
was a typical family vacation that just
blew your mind
well we went to florida a lot when i was
a kid
okay that was like where we were disney
or just like uh just
animal city shittiest places in florida
okay
what was the first time he traveled to
europe as a child when i was very my so
my mom
studied french literature in at
princeton and then got her phd
in french literature at yale and taught
french literature yale so she she speaks
french and then i spoke french because
of that
so we went to france that's where we
would go damn
but it was all like academic [ __ ] i
don't you know it's hard to
you're a partying at nine you know no
sure enough for sure smoking cigarettes
like this
holy [ __ ] yeah all right family of
skiers family
you guys ski yeah do you look down on
snowboarders
uh you snowboard no i ski that's you
looked out on snapchat i don't look
down on them i just i don't like them do
you rent skis or do you have your own
dude that can't be a real question
by the way the fact that you don't have
a passport is so
baffling because that means you can't
even go to canada dude what the [ __ ] am
i going up there in mexico
i mean places that are like dude he
can't even make it to delaware you're
worried about mexico
he's not going anywhere he just never
came up it never you know
why it doesn't just i don't just stumble
upon kayak.com
one day like oh flights to belize i
wonder what's happening
i want to see machu picchu i don't
that's not me have you been to machu
picchu i can't believe you asked him if
he rents skis
dude that's insane this guy was going to
france at six do you think he's got a
power
he got a pair of reynolds on holy [ __ ]
no but we were sensible we rented until
i stopped growing
and then smart with the gay [ __ ] that's
how you keep it
well we ask a lot of obviously we have a
lot of [ __ ] scumbag comics on sure
tend to be very trashy and one of the
big ones about skiing is we ask them if
they ever skied in jeans
and they all say yes often which is so
trashy i hope i want those people to get
hurt
themselves to get them off i want them
to stop for a while you know dude it's
all like crusted on the jeans
they got the powder all over the bottom
their knees look
so ghoulish and spindly
there was nothing cooler than a guy
skiing in jeans when i was a kid
at the spring mountain [ __ ] ski
resort you are not a go-kart
garbage were you skiing at one of those
you've never been skiing
i've been skiing a couple i'm more of a
more of a tubing type
you get me out on that thing i'm [ __ ]
hot dogging it down the slopes
it's got a plate of nachos on them
[ __ ] cruising sponge mckenzie in my
lap
i hate to say that my mind went to like
lake boat
tubing but yeah it did and then i was
like
there's not much yeah yeah jesus christ
no we we attempted to ski
uh a couple times when i was a kid i
hated it i'll share one lift ticket yeah
hanging under that tow rope getting drug
up the mountain is brutal
tow rope's not a mountain i mean that's
a hill
that's a that's the bunny slopes it was
scary dad's walking around his new
balance is at the bottom smoking six
i look also really quick uh actually i
shouldn't even say it
no we're busting balls right now of
course what
drug is not the past tense of drought
well he was getting drugged up on the
mountain so it's a little different he
was boofing [ __ ] perks
i love it i had to say it because that's
my drug is a funny one uh
no it was a drop like a dylan's well
time drop
youtube's
um where would you ski would you go to
like you know would you go like
trips or just like local places we
didn't go west you know
west that's well now yeah it's so long
but he's even go west yeah you got
skiing out west oh yeah
it's like going to the hamptons you're
going out east east
people i know it's directional when you
go what was the earliest you ever had
an oyster on the half shell i don't i
didn't like oysters at all
no what little kid does i was probably
like i was probably 22 or
three years oh okay yeah a little later
than you'd think all right
but we ate a lot i mean we lobster but
it was cheap and maine
that's true just get you getting a
couple of lobbies kid
yeah still in the traps yeah
um maine's beautiful they're up there
for the first time
uh a friend of mine's got a lot of
[ __ ] money and has a house up there
and it was like [ __ ] it
money goes a long way up there yeah land
is cheap i just
i was looking on like because we were up
there my girlfriend i were up there for
uh quarantine for like six months or
something
and i was looking on like zillow
oh you could get just for plots of land
yeah and like up in northern central
maine which is
remote you can get a 300 acres for
200 000 which is is that a lot
that's well it's so much land so much
land so much land
what are you gonna do build a go-kart
track save it
save it land isn't a non-renewable
resource
running out of land at some point not
only do you look at my taxes after this
i'll get my portfolio i got something on
my knee would you take a look at it i
don't know what it is
if it's i would love to land i would
long land would be cool
that's i have that there's there's such
romance to that because like we've been
in the city for
city living is [ __ ] tough especially
as a comedian like the mics outlay
work all that [ __ ] it's like it just
wears on you it's hot out there and then
i would just love to go get [ __ ] land
somewhere upstate new york
maine so [ __ ] it imagine just and just
leaving yeah just going i'm out here
having a place that that where you could
get lost
on your own property to get lost out in
the woods yeah yeah
300 acres 300 acres is a lot that's like
10
000 times what you're starving out there
the [ __ ] coyotes that get you
there's no coyotes at me i got invited
to go bear hunting in maine this
this year by who mark cuban black bear
hunting
and i are you a have you hunted no
i couldn't shoot a bear nor could i yeah
nor
a little black bear little snuggly one
do you know how they do it they go
bait it's bait traps so they basically
fill
a blue barrel with no joke honey
dunkin donuts donuts got my donkeys
for real they fill it with that and then
the bear
it's at the base of a tree a bear comes
and sniffs it out
and then they release the hounds and the
hounds tree the bear
and you have the hounds gps on their
collar and you're like driving on you
find them when they're all right i'm
running
circling a tree you hike into the woods
you see the bear and you shoot it dead
and it falls that's not true why would
you just shoot it when it's at the
donuts and you're up the tree
because you're not because you're so far
away you're in a car on another site
or whatever ah that's [ __ ] just go play
laser tag at that point
yeah um that's how they're going to get
me
barrel full of donuts walk right into
their trap
a couple of dogs jason yeah
use the big man's at the top of an
evergreen oh he's not a bear but we
probably still shoot him right i still
want that apple crawler
we can scumbags we can mount them and
put them in the game room
i thought i could just the way the like
the way his voice is when he said and
they use
for bait i thought they were i thought
you're going to sell like a poor kid or
something like that
i wish biddeford maine that was the name
of it i couldn't
ah yes benefit of course that's that is
a great
sort of uh you know it's the dividing
line
between trash and that is bitter class
bitter well well you have both there
yeah you really do
and but it's like bad it's trash people
and then it's
like it's wealthy yeah there's like a
big
mill or something that's like that my
friend's family
bought that and like they're like
rebuilding the whole town so we went up
there and it's like this huge complex
with like breweries and
bars and [ __ ] i think it's coming up
it's not too far from portland yeah it's
like 40 minutes portland's exploding
yeah yeah
all right let's knuckle down on this why
okay so why do you think you're trash
well um i sold cocaine for a bit
i don't see you properly let me get your
number i
i took i took my uh and i've told i've
said this before
but uh i when i was tutoring in new york
when i first got here and doing the mics
i wasn't making any money
i was working for a tutoring agency and
they just they would charge a lot for me
but i would get a very small percentage
of that
it's like a pimp and a hooker exactly
and i
uh i'm out here sucking it you know i
would
uh see that a lot of my friends were
getting into
cocaine and or people i knew were
getting into cocaine and and i saw that
the margins were a lot higher for that
than
margins you have just been training some
[ __ ] to take the [ __ ] psats i'd
imagine so
so uh i asked my a friend of mine
who was like not you know he'd kind of
he had some under
world connection sure nice and uh he
brought me to a stash house
in uh brownsville and we picked up a big
amount from this
guy named poppy that was his his
nickname yeah it's not government and it
was
it was uh a corner of the brick so it
was like
stuck together it was it was it had
clearly been compacted sure
and came over the border and the you
know maybe the foot of a teddy bear or
something
whatever so i had to then cut that
up i had to step on it i didn't step on
it what
no because i was going to charge a lot
for it since yeah and so i wanted
whatever to be good
but i'm only sweating over here those
little scales i had to buy one of those
and then i had to go find those tiny
ziploc bags joanne's fabrics
i could not find them any gas station
711 that you go to for those
won't sell them to you even if they have
it because they know what you want it
for
damn so i had to use loose sandwich bags
which totally it's a mess
nah that's actually pretty nice and you
did you twist it i did
but it wasn't nice it looked you know it
looked like [ __ ] it was the worst
presence
he's worried about his [ __ ] product
design on the [ __ ] eight ball yeah
this was really
you know those were easier to get into
to be honest so so so i've heard
yeah but everyone likes the little one
because you can dip your key in so
true so then i did that for a bit and
uh ended up just breaking even because i
was financing my own supply
nice and then uh that's when i started
well one of my friends got arrested for
cocaine okay for possession
yeah you had given him no okay he'd
gotten it from somewhere else but
he and then that opened my eyes like
just out at night
yeah he went behind like he left walked
out of a bar and went over to the sort
of side alley
and then went in there and was like and
then these cops came up they'd seen them
go in
yeah with flashlights and in the city no
in montauk oh they're looking again east
hampton police
oh really and they spent the night in
the two of my friends and
oh this is crazy so one of them had
bought two little bags
and the other had only bought one and
the weight of the cocaine
in the two bags knocked it up to a
felony
for that kid and then my other buddy
only got a misdemeanor
like possess them small possessions damn
good to know keep the little on you
folks
or eat it when you see the [ __ ] fuzz
coming sure don't eat it
all right i got one here have you ever
had a manicure no
oh i would have paid the i don't just
just you know i don't know anything that
we just jumped away from that
i i don't see any garbage in that place
no selling narcotics selling high-end
coke crash though that's not like that's
normal
like in his circles he's frowned upon
you're like
i'm not kidding you picture this okay so
i'm in
my apartment with i live with three of
my harvard buddies
and i'm selling cocaine out of my sock
drawer they're going out every day
to their finance jobs and making
hundreds of thousands of dollars did
they know that you were
they kind of had an idea because people
would come in and buy it from me and i
was the my
downfall as a dealer was that i was too
generous and i would always give people
like a taste with me
before they like bought it and i only
had
one framed glass actually had two i had
two framed glass surfaces in my room one
was a picture of my family
and the other was my harvard degree and
i felt
too like it was too [ __ ] up to do
cocaine off my parents faces
so i would take the harvard degree off
off the wall put it between my
legs chop up some lines and do give give
away cocaine to people
jesus oh it sounds like a right and
there's something very
eye-opening when you're doing that where
you're looking down at your harvard
degree and you're like there has to be a
better use for this
okay sure i'll give you that yeah that's
trashy it
it's definitely trashy for sure i don't
think it's going to make you
did the roommates kick you out or
anything or they no
i couldn't afford it anymore after eight
months i i left oh you left
okay all right did you continue to set
to sell after that no i
i only sold for like a a you know a
couple batches
okay i would call it and and then i was
just like jesus what am i what am i
[ __ ] doing
yeah this isn't pretty worth it
all right i can see that i haven't done
cocaine in about nine years now
that was nine years ago yeah that was
2011 yeah nice
well it's also he doesn't think that's
trashy because he's a coke addict for
like 10 years so you're going like
yeah i wouldn't say that when my parents
are watching hey mom hey dad good to see
you
kippy's uh hitting the booze parents
listen to their podcast what about now
i'm handcuffed
can't talk about your past and the
meatloaf was great last weekend ma
yeah no but i just see that as a class
that's more miami vice than like uh um
uh the wire it's also far from miami
advice he was living with four other
people
but they went to harvard kevin i
understand talking about class
but i see where he's coming from he's
selling coke out of his [ __ ]
roommate's apartment you know what
diploma you can't do cocaine off of one
that you didn't get
all right shout out to weiner university
manicure i have not had one no
pedicure no massage sure well uh this is
when was the last massage you had
a long time ago okay i mean i certainly
you know obviously covets out and then
probably
probably a couple years before that
really i got one three days ago
oh yeah they're up and running huh yeah
60 bucks sometimes sometimes if they
don't
they don't feel good about the ming
twenty dollars that's that's
like yeah anything that walks on your
back like i don't want that no she
doesn't walk with that walk on your back
they have a little bar on the ceiling
no that's what you want i've had that
that's that's the like
35 no no this is a girl it's just a full
body massage
i'll do it for 10. i'll get the kinks
i'll pay you 10. when it's 10 bucks a
pack of blow i'll come over this weekend
why is there a fat guy in francis's room
walking on his back
okay um do you sneak snacks into the
movie theater
yeah oh do you brush your teeth in this
i'll i'll do
one more i'll do one more i i will sneak
dinner into the movie
i hate that and i'll sneak dinner in i
cooked
myself oh what god i
i will bring in like steamed broccoli
brown rice and you know broiled chicken
breasts and i'll have a actual
metal knife and fork that's organic i
don't believe in
that's insane level of trash
what do you put it in tupperware you put
it at the bottom of your girlfriend's
purse the
the theater we go to doesn't check the
guy doesn't care it's definitely glass
tupperware i would assume right it sure
is
yeah it's uh yeah glad you know
tupperware
you can't i don't think i've ever i've
never even in all of my trap i've never
even thought of making food
you've made it home well uh sometimes
the movie conflicts
directly with dinner time and you've got
to eat and uh you don't want to
you know you're not going what are you
going to say [ __ ] pizza box in no
no but i was asking like [ __ ] gob
stoppers or something
you're going three course meals i've
done that but for the sake of the
podcast
i've done far worse i love it that's it
so wow that really might have that's
that's trashier than selling blood it's
a weird type of trash because it's
[ __ ] steamed broccoli brown rice and
[ __ ] broiled chicken
that's that's that makes it what that
makes it
classy
[Applause]
i mean he's eating right what do you
want dude what are you taught he's
making food an hour ahead of time
traveling to the [ __ ]
but it's healthy usually it'll be like a
leftover i'll bring leftovers into the
movie that's even worse
that's bad that's insane i'd rather you
cook the meal or stop and get a chalupa
or something on the way and sneak in i
think cooking something for the movie
theater is
is ridiculous that would be ridiculous
this is all ridiculous francis that is
next level insanity i i can't comment
leftovers to the [ __ ]
movie theater i've eaten a lot of [ __ ]
in the movie theater it's never been
steamed i've never had a piece of
broccoli
you've never had a piece of broccoli i
was watching ghostbusters so i got
a couple of deep-fried oreos i gotta say
that's pretty good man
that's impressive i like how you're just
you it's because it's healthy you think
that's okay behavior
what about the [ __ ] poor schmuck next
to him when he breaks out boiled [ __ ]
let those peasants deal with themselves
you know what
what allowed me to think that doing that
was okay
i went to the theater i used to go to in
brooklyn
that there would be people that had full
mcdonald's yeah it gets hairy
and i would be like well if they're
eating dinner and it's this [ __ ] like
okay i can eat dinner in the movies and
my dinner just looks a lot better
that's some waspy [ __ ] right there well
they're over there eating
eating eating they're fast food yeah
they're handed out hamburgers like who
got what you know
i said no tomatoes holy dude
that's that's unforgivable in my book
that's insane
i don't think so you are a [ __ ]
animal so
if it was like meatloaf or spaghetti or
some [ __ ] like that yeah
but it's [ __ ] low carb high protein
lean fat
doesn't matter what it is he's taking a
picture i probably only want to
go to the gym afterwards real quick for
a steam and a workout ah we're growing
maybe a face you're growing so far apart
that's insane what about brushing your
teeth in the shower how do you feel
about that
i have no problem with that i don't he's
a savage he takes leftovers to the
[ __ ] movie theater i don't do it uh
anymore as often but for years and years
i did it okay would you leave the
toothbrush in the shower
accidentally i would but i would know i
would not mean to do that okay
that's that word a little bit of saving
grace now as we've established you come
from a good lineage
upper middle class beginnings as you
said in your father's business really
took off
uh well-educated how do you feel okay
because my associate here on the podcast
is a staunch
does not believe that this is a quality
know what he's gonna say
do you take leftovers home from a
restaurant
yeah yeah absolutely and i
eat them at the movie theater no
homemade food at the movie theater i'm
sorry
i'm sorry where did you go to school
again where was your your college
harvard harvard university thank you
do you guys differ on that one oh yeah
this has been
content this guy doesn't take leftovers
uh why not
well okay this cuz he's a bozo and he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing one i finish it okay well that's
fair and i'm not saying
not taking it is classy that's not i'm
not saying it's like a classy move to
leave
i'm not saying that i'm saying to take
you know a quarter of a chicken breast
and four pieces of asparagus home
to me i just go that's it's garbage
because if you don't take it
it's literal trash so it's i first of
all i finished not if i'm waiting the
table yeah
i mean i mean it's still it's still food
i understand that that's why i finish it
i don't i'm never in a position so okay
i have an interesting
uh addendum lay it on us which would be
that
i get anxiety when i go to a new
restaurant
that i'm not going to order the best
stuff that they have
i will always ask the waiter what's the
best stuff you've got
you know and maybe they say like one or
two or three things
but i will over order to
quell the anxiety of having missed out i
get
fomo big time at restaurants does that
make sense what's fomo fear of mystery
you're missing out ah
so like i i cause i fear i'm never gonna
come back to this place
and i'd rather just hit it once and
order like way too much stuff
but uh make sure that i can taste
everything does that make sense
makes sense now that makes for a nice
leftover that's exactly right
that's why my leftovers are are worth at
least another full meal you're talking
about
i'm talking about if you go and you
order a bowl of spaghetti or whatever a
bowl of pasta
there's a quarter of it left you didn't
finish it i'm not saying
i'm classy for not taking it i'm just
saying i think it's trashy
i intentionally over order because i
rely on myself to eat the leftovers as
another meal
so i think it's a different point of
view we've got sure yeah i understand
that's a different situation as well
because you're ordering
over the top there's there's sort of a
triangle of opinion here
where none of us are on seem to be on
the same page but it's cool everyone's
got what do you mean i'm with you 100 i
want to go to dinner with you right now
yeah but you have a little over ordering
yeah well true
yeah yeah okay we i together on that
hang out with the kid
maybe see if pepe is still around what
was his name
the guy in brooklyn who is your guy in
brooklyn oh
poppy poppy yeah yeah brownsville check
him out too
oh poppy by the way oh you mean poppy
poppy's a little sloppy poppy's a little
sloppy
all right okay okay growing up did you
have milk with dinner
uh i was always lactose intolerant
from a very young age and not in like a
[ __ ] pathetic
nerdy you know [ __ ] like
single mom type of way i hate to say it
wait why what does that mean you're not
not like i
ch i get a little gassy i i would i
would really get sick
if i had dairy at all so i was on soy
milk most of my life
and then switched over to um almond oh
now i'm on oat
yeah holy [ __ ] oh yeah dude oatley's
nice ten days a week
everybody loves it um we took a shot at
single moms too that's classy right yeah
i don't know if i should have said that
i feel like i shouldn't have said that
um i meant like yoga mom it's pedigree
it's what it is you're calling you're
calling it
it's not like a it's not like a
lifestyle choice it's not like i want to
do this because it's
well they say lactose intolerant and
that means a very different thing
to me from what i said like i was
almost like allergic sure to lactose
like people come in and say that they
have a gluten allergy when they really
don't yeah
you just get a little sleepy so do we
all yeah you know or i have ocd i get
nervous it's like some people actually
have severe ocd and some people are like
oh i get weird in a situation there was
a girl
in his level at my high school who told
everyone she had a gluten allergy but
then she would just eat the pasta anyway
and then throw it up and we were like
you just have an eating disorder yeah
that was how it was we all saw it
and she kept you know oh celiac's
disease oh that's what it's called
celiac
don't piss on my face and tell me it's
raining
10 days a week don't piss off this guy's
got slogans i like it sure dude
that's great um have you ever been to a
hair cuttery
no oh okay i didn't think so what is
that
it sounds like he doesn't even know what
it is it's like a super it's like a
supercuts yeah
who does cut your hair a barber a barber
a barber
not a stock certainly not what's a hair
haircut run you now what are you
spending what are you dropping on a
haircut
plus tip it's plus tip let us know drop
it on us
it's so funny you ask this i i swear to
god
it no it's it's 50 bucks it's like 50 to
55 bucks manhattan it makes sense yeah
but
here's what's funny what with tip or tip
on top of that
with tip that's 55 with tip yeah okay so
the haircuts what 30 40.
it's like 40 bucks 10 15 on tip okay now
shabby
now here's the thing though when it's
got a good headache i got
fired from my my job at barstool
and i had i stopped to make i didn't
make
much as much money for a while obviously
until i went and worked for broadband
you were doing well over there
at barcelo yeah yeah yeah i i was making
a good salary okay and
um i i just didn't have
much money and the first change that i
made in my life
was to go from 55 haircuts to
19 haircuts there's a difference
dude my i look like [ __ ] i know it was
it was so
nice it was unbelievable i know i would
have loved to been there on a friday
night you coming out of your first 19
years oh my gosh oh my god it was
[ __ ] revolting did you ever have
somebody cut your hair when you're like
i know you don't even care that you're
doing that they're just like looking
or it's like you're arguing with this
guy
who does not speak any english over what
is best for your hair and he has his
idea
and he won't meet you in the middle no
he says no i'm giving you this
if you want a better haircut earn more
money yeah
that's the way they play it dude if you
can get a really good expensive haircut
in new york or you can like [ __ ] slum
it
or you don't have a say you just get
what they give you and they and they
they
set up their waiting chairs on the
sidewalk outside because the place is so
small you they you can't even have where
is it
it's one of those like floating shops
okay you know what i mean like
in in a [ __ ] under an awning
somewhere i don't know do you have a guy
when
uh so the you're back to the 55 dollar
haircut you're back to your now i've
gone back you're back he's making a
little bit
good yeah um do you have a specific guy
you go to
i do yeah do you make an appointment or
do you walk in
and wait for him i make an appointment
okay yeah i don't have the heart when i
walk in
to wait i feel bad for the poor schmuck
in the back
yeah and i always go and they always
[ __ ] me up every time i know
i'd rather have a bad haircut than hurt
that guy's feelings
that's that's a good that means you're
not as garbage i think everybody knows
that though if you
if you have your own barber in in a
multiple barber situation they know
you're waiting for your guy i always get
terry in the back
[ __ ] terry hmm mother terry's just my
guy now dude
i'm like no i'm waiting for terry real
bad
and i think i've got a lot left terror
you [ __ ] step your game up
have terry ruin my week real quick i uh
i like russian barbers now
new york you gotta go they're all it's
all russian i want russia yeah or like
eastern europeans
yeah yeah yeah for sure my barber knows
english
about he this guy speaks really good
english and he knows so much about
what's going on in russia politically
that i go in and i learn
from him that's pretty good and i
actually really enjoy it he because he's
i've like fact checked him
after the fact and he was dead right and
i'm like what's this guy what's the
scoop what's cooking over there
well he says that the current conflict
between azerbaijan and armenia
is actually a much more likely scenario
to lead to world war three
than anything that would occur between
america russia or china
damn why because it's a proxy it's being
fought over this
tiny tiny parcel of land but there are
so many kind of
ethnic and religious considerations like
turkey wants
the muslims to win because they are
predominantly muslim country i mean it
and then
there's so there's the outside forces
that are like aiding from the back
based on their own you know interests
interests and
and it's pulling more people in look at
that
i think you're old class dude that was
way better than my russian barber my
russian barber looked like a bad guy
from a bond movie
i cut my hair in the shoe as if i wanted
a 12 year old kid
he's good he's fresh i tell you i cut
back straight or you want
natural tell me if you want a little
girl let me know
she's virgin um okay this i can't
foresee this
does your family um
ever participate in the ritual known as
a yankee swap or white elephant
what i don't i don't know okay that's
where it's like a you know polly
pollyanna secret santa i don't know
where the [ __ ] you got those
i've never even heard of pollyanna but
i've heard of the secret santa
all right so it's a secret well then
yeah it's a secret santa where everybody
buys a gift
and then you like fight over it's real
trash it's a real
trash say it again have you ever been to
a fair that had 50 50 raffle tickets yes
oh really yes owned the land it was in
maine
the winner got a jaguar uh not the car
um what no so every say there's the
three of us right and we all pull a
number one we all buy a gift not for
anybody but just to see
this is trashy this is real we didn't do
that we we did a straight polyam which
is still kind of trashy but whatever
it's uh you all buy just a nondescript
gift anybody could use right you all put
it in the middle and then they're all
wrapped up you don't know what they are
and then we all pull a number one
through three
number one pulls first so say you open
it up and it's a [ __ ] flowbee to get
to cut your hair
oh cool and then i can either take from
the pot
or i can take your gift okay and that
can you but you do
you do it with like 10 people wait have
you ever gotten a flowbee as a gift tell
me please tell me yes
no but my my sister-in-law's dad
invented the flowbee
oh really yeah
invented the technology then leased it
to easy pass this is your
sister-in-law's
dad he's an inventor like a proper
inventor good for him
yeah that's cool i mean the easy pass is
just an enormously
helpful thing what a development yeah
for traffic
think about it get it do you ever see
people at a toll
i just i don't have it dude
what are you doing i just got it last
week the new one for me that's pathetic
i know
i didn't have a car for a long time a
new one for me this one is this one is
merging into this territory but it's not
there yet
when i go to the airport i have uh clear
or
yeah yeah tsa pre-check and so
i love that and i look down on people
that are in the pedestrian line
sure but it's not it's still a sense of
superiority rather than
how could you be such an idiot as to not
have this sure
which is what i feel about it easy pass
yeah yeah of course of course
you're breaking out changing in my
defense i
when i had my car in new york i had i
had it and then i got rid of my car
yeah i took my car back to my parents
and it sat there for three years and
then i don't know
six eight months ago i brought it back
and i just never [ __ ] got it right
and then i just got it um
but they're getting rid of them because
now because of covid so you just drive
through and it's all by mail
anyway have you ever gone through have
you ever not had easy pass and gone
through
a toll and not had the money to pay for
it no
i have but by accident again and then i
had to settle it up in the mail
yeah i had to do that too once i knew
that
i knew damn well that i wasn't able to
pay for [ __ ] i was driving to
virginia sorry i took the wrong car
i got my mom's car my wallet's in my
other car um all right i got one you're
a classy guy
a couple of bucks probably live in a
nice apartment yeah why do you want to
be garbage i feel like you're
disappointed
i never said i wanted to they just said
i got a darker side
i can't pretend that i'm some totally uh
you know unimpeachable person
yeah um the word impeachable that's
class
if i were to go to your house right now
right mean foley come over we sit down
we both ask for water do you live with
your lady friend
i do okay we both ask for water
what are you offering us great question
i'm going to
take a glass out of the cupboard and i'm
going to fill it up for you guys
from our brita filter in the
refrigerator okay that's a that's a
valuable
val valid answer that's the answer a
bottle of water is very nice but i know
you're not all big on plastic no not at
all i don't keep bottles of water
yes uh i picked up on the uh i like the
glass pellegrinos and uh gyro listeners
that's the if someone offered if i went
and asked for a water and someone gave
me a pellegrino yeah i'd be like
how do i take from you in life what can
i take from you
we're big we're big on the we're big on
that at our house my wife's european so
that's all it's just all the [ __ ]
all it is let me tell you something
everybody i know when people go to a
restaurant all right all right
i'm talking to the fans out there all
right maybe on a tight budget
when you go to a restaurant and they
offer you a bottle of sparkling or still
i swear to god skip the soda and [ __ ]
get that
it is so [ __ ] worth it what i
totally disagree and why yes
tap every time almost at some like i i i
don't
sense of not wanting to be an [ __ ] no
you go with the bottle no joke when i
was single
i went on a date with a girl once who
jumped in and
as i was saying tap's fine and it was
like sure bottle is great
and they brought it was like 14 what's
the one with the orange label they give
it to you in the green room at
caroline's all the time
awkward
and it was a big bottle and i knew i ate
bucks immediately wrote this girl off
yeah
we were not at all compatible yeah
i'm a big steel guy uh the worst the
worst
answer you could have given is uh do you
ever go to someone's house and they give
you
a glass of water and the glasses and
it's like
they like just wash the glass out of the
sink and you're like i'm like nah dude
i'll [ __ ] yeah i'm good you smell like
old soap and garlic in it yeah that's
[ __ ] what if they
what if they pointed you to the sink and
you were and they were just like put
your head under there
i would have i probably have some
friends where that's the that's the case
yeah i love drinking from the hose
well a hose would be different yeah
drink it from the from the from the
faucet of the bathroom late at night
when you're dying of thirst is good too
i don't like it yeah you're getting a
sideways sip
it's not good it's too much energy to
get what you need yeah
it's not harder to breathe i go to i
take a i water every night that's the
last thing we do
water next to the bed yeah yeah yeah and
then we got it
i try to throw a move on the old lady
she turns me down break out the crippler
and then what you have your water in the
middle of the night when you wake up
yeah i wake up a lot i pee a lot
uh i need some water you know do you how
many times do you pee
ever when you're sleeping through the
night i hold it every time uh
at least once you get up at least once a
night in the middle of the night yeah
yeah yeah dude that's crazy yeah i hold
it i used to pee the bed a lot
as a kid oh i just got a tiny bladder to
go with a tiny pee pee i have a friend
who gets up three times a night
that's a lot that would be like tight
that's the smallest bladder ever
and he's a big dude there's nothing
worse than that i hold it as long as i
can and
until like it affects my dreams my sleep
yeah and i'm just
angry but dude that release it's like
you're sitting there like roll tossing
and rolling around
that pain is never gonna go away but you
gotta you gotta get it out you know what
too
i [ __ ] you know my girl's always on
me about like you know missing the
toilet and peeing on the floor
i go in there in the middle of the night
half asleep it's [ __ ] it's on the
walls
i don't know what's going on why don't
you you more men are
this is something i'm learning a lot
more men are are sitting down to people
it's not comfortable for me i
agree i don't feel like i'm clearing the
cylinder as much
yeah i feel like i'm peeing back on
myself you
gravity to to help yeah in that process
yeah
and i hate getting pee on my um on my
area mm-hmm very smelly
i don't like it oh man well ladies
you're something
your piss strikes me as being very very
dark yellow oh you wouldn't like it yeah
not a lot of water in there
thick yeah there's a lot it's a lot of
[ __ ] you know
vitamins and nutrients coming in it
would be like that guy aaron ralston who
got his arm trapped under the rock in
127 hours
so he had to drink his own pee yours is
like the third
the third cycle of that third generation
you've gone through a couple times and
your bladders have sorted out
any remaining nutrients and it's just
mud now it's bad
it looks like my pee looks like mountain
dew most of the time
and when i have a you're so unhealthy
when i have a spit when i have asparagus
it comes out as a whole one comes comes
out wrapped up
wrapped up in bacon no when i have
asparagus it instantly smells so bad
yeah that's that's true
i know but with my added people my added
regular uh
unleaded that i usually run it makes it
nice
this guy's burning high octane over here
pure diesel it makes for a really weird
smell like he's the whole bathroom
it's like coyote pee or something like
that marking my trail
so i know how to get it they sell it at
[ __ ]
i forget the name guys i gotta tell you
i'm having a lot of fun
i really do here buddy great fun that's
what we do yeah i like this
all right i got a couple more i think um
when was the last time you were in a
wave pool
long long time probably 12 or 13 one of
those
vacations to florida roller coaster uh
not as long as as you might well i was i
was 22
it was my senior year that's that's the
right answer yeah yeah ever work at a
kiosk in the mall
no ever have did you have a job growing
up sure
what'd you do yeah uh one summer i
was like a referee of all these like
kids youth soccer and
classes that's a classy classy job
that and the tutoring uh-huh and then i
did uh
i worked at a uh i painted a porches
for an entire summer that's just porches
like
mostly it was mostly like decks and
porches like start a pro painters or
whatever one of those
i was just freelancing but i got a
couple jobs like people would refer me
and
whatever wait you were doing it yourself
yeah wow see
industrial started his own business and
then i did i worked at yo like this i
worked as a
at a kayak and canoe what's up
ready to yeah place and i would pull the
boats off the
hooks and like give them to families to
go out in the ocean
that was a summer where i was working at
this very ritzy area of maine called
prout's neck roger goodell has his
summer house there
okay and they have a famous old hotel
called the black point inn and i made
friends with all of the wealthy
new york kids that were there and i
would play beer pong and they're
screened in porches and take advantage
of them and stuff
and they one day brought me after work
to the black point in for tea
they set out all these little finger
sandwiches and they had a grand piano
in the little area there and i sat down
and started yeah you played
the manager of the hotel walked out and
offered me a job
playing the piano two nights a week on
the spot
and i went from making like eight
dollars an hour at my canoe and kayak
rental place to making
fifty dollars for four hours of playing
just two nights a week
and like tripled my weekly salary what'd
you would you play that bloom away would
you like piano man i don't even know
what i was i don't even remember
rendering
with a puppy in the stadium chopsticks
but it was like it was
one of those amazing just fortuitous
moments of like being in the right place
at the right
time and then like getting into you know
the richer circle
sure that allowed what it's all about
baby make more money it's all about that
network i gotta stop hanging out with
you no [ __ ] i will tell you working
around
rich people is is helpful i know my
niece is making
my niece and nephew are in private
school and i've been networked with some
of their friends
see if they need their porches painted
they're only eight and nine but still
um i used to work at a law firm that
represented international billionaires
that was like my last
my last day job and when you're working
around that kind of like i used to
manage their apartments in new york i
mean like hundred million dollar
apartments and [ __ ] yeah it's like you
it's just
do you go into some of those yeah yeah
yeah yeah i just have sometimes have to
go like reset the wi-fi or whatever
you're like whatever you know
or like go yell at a neighbor and you're
you're one of 25 people there that day
who are
who are fixing something or like
cleaning or teaching oh yeah yeah they
wouldn't and like a lot of them wouldn't
even know me yeah like i would have to
like also i'd have to fund the accounts
from like all it's all like shell
corporations and getting money in the
u.s
so i'd have to i'd be on the phone with
like [ __ ] you know hong kong being
like i need two million stat in the
you know to the to the bvi account and
then like and i'm like you don't even
know me and i'm ordering around two
million dollars of your money dude the
best the best
gig i had when i was tutoring was i got
hired by a very
very wealthy family i mean blew the
other orders of magnitude greater than
than the other upper east side families
had
and this guy you know he had a big
family
and a staff of 15 which included
two chefs who cooked all the dinners
yeah damn
and the kids would come through there
were a lot of kids in the family they
would come through and they would fill
their plates or whatever
and then with me and the other tutor who
were full time
uh got to make our plates and these guys
these chefs were had worked at
the top right yeah la bernard and uh 11
madison park like you know
michelin starred restaurants and i was
eating
you know what would have been a hundred
and thirty dollar entrepreneur
every night that's wait how are you full
time
so i got hired that family wanted
like a total commitment so i sh i pushed
my other students
off to other tutors that i had hired i
took a percentage of what they were
making
and then i worked a couple of points a
kid gets to let his big
holy [ __ ] on contract for that family
what so you have to be there every day
yeah five days a week after sunday
through thursday
but there were perks i mean they had a
lot of perks they had a sick ski house
that they would take
a helicopter to and i would i would
accompany them sometimes on the
helicopter
why okay what would be the under the the
kids had homework on the weekends and if
the parents sometimes like the parents
wouldn't come
and so they would send you know a tutor
and two nannies
and like it's all outsourced yeah out
with the kids the ski house
on the helicopter yeah yeah holy [ __ ] i
used to there was this how are the
nannies are they hot
dude no but
there was i mean there something [ __ ]
insane
happened uh which is straight out of
like you know
upstairs downstairs or downton abbey or
some [ __ ] where
never seen it the the chef was and the
and then that one of the nannies started
having an affair
nice and they were both married to like
other people nice and
uh they were doing a ton of drugs nice
ecstasy
nice and then the nanny was like driving
the little kids to surf camp in the
morning
and and was too [ __ ] up and they found
this out and they can
and they were also stealing wine from
the wine cellar
that's what you're getting you can't do
that these guys know their wine you
can't steal
it was one of the maids who found the
empty bottles of wine
and snitched on them and then when the
dad
confronted the chef the chef picked up a
vaz
in the kitchen and threw it at his head
he ducked
and it broke through the stained glass
window that they had had
done special for that house and then
they i think they called the police
and the chef got arrested and taken away
of course he did that happened in front
of the [ __ ] kids man
that's probably not even the craziest
thing that's happening that was the
craziest thing that i was like
of course i arrived the next day and the
kids ran out the driveway to greet me
and they were like you're never gonna
believe what happened
and i was like this is awesome
let's get in the helicopter talk about
that helicopter to the ski resort
yeah you've been in a helicopter on your
way to go skiing
yeah but uh you know as a pa total as it
passes
my mom was friends with a lady whose
husband was the kind of used to fly the
with the weather channels
you get to sit in the back we're up here
there's uh traffic on 95.
i'm living an eye on a car chase
go lower no i was too scared to go
it was right around halloween i remember
my brother this [ __ ] thing came down
the runway
it was huge land i was like nah [ __ ]
that let's go to [ __ ] clover get some
gi joes
but my brother went for like a 20 minute
ride yeah helicopters are spooky
wow they're not you don't think you
think you're in a
tin yeah of sardines yeah so my one of
my family's friends used to fly he had
one and he would fly it like
recreationally and i remember all the
kids like we're going in [ __ ] mister
whatever this thing i'm like
i was like six like dude you are not
[ __ ] getting me in that yeah unless
you're a [ __ ]
huey vietnam vet pilot i'm not getting
into a [ __ ] chopper with you i want
somebody with military training that and
i didn't i was right that when i was in
sea world they pulled me up to like play
with shamu or whatever and i was like
not today chief you are not pulling me
up to [ __ ]
get eaten by this [ __ ] thing thank
some others
in front of a whole sea world not doing
it i think it's part of the show
oh look his arm's gone nope
uh have you ever been to busch gardens
williamsburg
no but i've been to busch gardens
florida orlando i assume
oh wow have you ever been to myrtle
beach for a vacation no
that's trash have you ever owned a lava
lamp no
okay black light no but i had those
glow-in-the-dark
stars that you would that was like that
was like the intro to like you really
wanted a black like
i was like i wanted like black light
poster i was like we'll start with the
stuff that was the intro to smoking
dubias
did you guys ever have a door made of
beans
oh that's a question no but i wanted no
way your mom
no way your mom was going for that yeah
we that's a question that's come up on
the show a bunch really goddamn i
thought that was an
original thought no i think we just
asked it like two weeks ago maybe yeah
[ __ ] me twice yeah it's uh still
trashy um that is trashy edges anything
you could buy at spencer's gifts as home
decor just trash yeah this is garbage
that's how i come up with
questions for the show i go just go to
spencer's wednesday i love it um
have you ever bought a necklace with a
charm on it no okay
okay like a bead okay at a county fair a
hemp
necklace with a bead yeah that's all
right that was cool back yeah at that
age that was
that was in what i could see him wearing
every one of those wear a puka shell
necklace
no i i not not a shell one but i had
like
those sort of abercrombie boy necklaces
when i was in seventh grade for sure
i did rock those and i popped my collar
you did and i once wore a shirt two
shirts
and topped
you will put two polos on and pop both
of them as
though your collars were spooning each
other
it's it's a it was a layering it was way
past
your time yeah you would usually do the
white one on the inside and then the
color one on the outside
i had a buddy that did it like we were
way too old it wasn't even
cool and he would like show up to the
ball like we were like 23 or whatever
he would show up to the ball with three
pop collars on no
swear to god dude that's too much um i'm
throwing a blank one that's [ __ ] name
shout out to quiggs i mean and stateside
vodka but at that point you're not even
starting a hot
company you're wearing three shirts yeah
but you know it's a year it's a
conversation starter [ __ ]
no it's not it's a comment we're talking
about it we're talking about it
years later the kid's still got some
heat do you pop your collar now or no
no he's a [ __ ] gentleman not in deca
a decade
or more i thought that's what i thought
that's what cool people did was pop your
collar
i this is making me want to try it again
i want to bring it back you could pull
it off because you're tall
good in shape and you're like oh that's
good that's a fashion choice but that
guy you couldn't
i couldn't when you go to brunch do you
wear sunglasses
do you wear sunglasses at brunch only
only to the restaurant and then i take
them off do you wear flip-flops in the
city
no i got one this is this has been a
very
divisive one based on foley's answer uh
you're out you know it's obviously not
ideal but you're out somewhere and you
have to
uh you have to use the bathroom and
number two right you gotta use a public
restroom
how do what's the ritual how do you
clean the seat in a public restroom
yeah you know i've just bought something
more
secure about this as i've grown older i
used to be very
germaphobic about it and i you know but
now
uh honestly i give it a glance
and if i'm like it looks pretty clean
dry i
i'll just take i'll sit down but then if
there's any kind of
anything untoward i will get a ball
of toilet paper a thick ball and then
use that as a somewhat of a squeegee and
then just hold my breath
yeah foley why don't you tell them what
you do um well
i like to poop in the evenings um now i
will
similar situation like when it looks
clean there's not like [ __ ] on the
toilet or anything like that
yeah you're gonna be blown away i will
get that same
said chunk of toilet paper i will flush
the toilet a couple of times to get
fresh water in there
a couple of times yeah like just to get
you know fresh water
hold on may i pause you i'm so sorry do
you flush it wait
until it replenishes and then flush it
again yeah those industrial well the way
you
did it you were like it sounded like you
were pumping it
those the ones that like you know that
don't have the rocket
ship washers yeah done in the tank yeah
so you're just ripping that thing
to create like a vacuum of some kind to
get the water fresh and then i take the
ball of toilet paper i dip it a little
bit just a touch in the water
why don't you wet it under the sink
because i gotta go out with the whole
topic in my hand everyone knows i'm
taking a poop
did anyone have doubts when you flush
the toilet four times or you're in the
stall
i could be doing bumps they don't know
maybe i'm trying how insane is that
that guy's flushing a lot of cocaine
down the toilet
he uses toilet bowl walls that's gross
man
well in a weird way it explains why
you're flushing it so many times which
environmentally again that hurts me but
i now i understand it
yeah that's my move what have you see
what if you see
like stalactite on the on the corner
yeah
chunks i'm gonna go to a different stall
yeah i'm going to hold it
or i'm not going to do the wiping method
and i'm just going to wipe it down and
and make it happen
so why why must it be wet that makes the
seat wet which
to me is unknown i dry it off i dry it
off so you go well he's doing a lot of
work in there and then you take another
ball
and then you if i need you're the reason
that the
rain forest is big there you go
i'm pretty environmentally conscious in
other ways you guys are drinking that
plastic cups
true i got my true foley mug right here
oh okay uh let's just do one or two we
gotta wrap up then we'll do one or two
of like the standards um
growing up butter was it kept in the
refrigerator or kept on the counter and
where do you keep it now
refrigerator and then it now it's in the
refrigerator in that little
top on the floor on the door yeah uh the
top thing
with a little see-through wow he has one
of those i got one of those
do you yeah you have a butter thing in
your refrigerator yeah you die
every refer that's not like oh i know
what you're talking about yeah i thought
you meant like you had a separate can
you access it from the outside
no okay what not
dog doggy door
well you look like michael fassbender a
little bit gotten that i like him what a
great actor oh he's so fast he speaks
like seven languages too
you french how many that's all you got
plays the piano were you classically
trained as a piano player
i mean that's such a it's such a like
fancy way i took
lessons in classical piano but i
couldn't say that i was
trained by some sensei pianist so at
that
at that place in the hamptons or
wherever you were where you were working
the summer gig
yeah you weren't you weren't playing
like billy joel you were playing like i
was playing i was reading
music yeah playing classical music wow
i'd wear a suit for it uh yeah i'd play
some mozzarella that's not
wagner no vogner no i think
mostly wagner's orchestral okay uh
i think certainly not shakespeare
goosebumps checkberry
this this has to be a yes but this is
another recurring one
if you had to go to a wedding tomorrow
right you find out today you gotta go to
a wedding you have a suit that fits you
correct yeah you can put on a suit
tomorrow
and not have to worry about it yes
however
i have had suits that i've chosen vetoed
by my girlfriend
due to stains that i did not think were
deal breakers sure
that's a big thing yeah oh okay how many
suits do you
own currently well good question and i
have a follow-up
i would probably say like three that's
pretty good
but but i have two i have two that i
bought
on sale as like a big deal that i
haven't
hemmed yet okay so this this the pant
looks uncircumcised
okay yeah yeah so i have them but
they're not ready to go
but you could in a pinch you got you
have one that you can put on and go to
it
i own five suits two of which are holy
[ __ ] i mean they're you know the one
those those ones that i bought were like
200 bucks yeah he doesn't own a suit so
anyway you're like i only got five
they're only two and a buck i think i
still think that's less weird to me than
not having a passport
yeah um do you have do you own a tux yes
what
i'm gonna sound douchey here most of the
weddings that i get invited to
are black ties which i find very cash
i find that very indulgent upon the on
the side of that are you running that
circle
hold on have you ever been to a wedding
that was cash bar
no yeah i don't think i have either i
might have been one like a kid back in
the day at like a vfw or something like
that
i've been to a funeral that was cash i
went to a wedding that was
july which was
really offensive that's tough i i went
to one
it was because the one of the someone in
the wedding party sober the wedding
party the wedding party no i mean
i i think either the pride party i was
gonna say i'm not [ __ ] i'm not having
to drive money for cousin steve
yeah yeah he [ __ ] got it come on man
you can't do that to people i respect it
you know them they're making choices
about in their lives but come on
so we're [ __ ] standing around
drinking shirley temples like [ __ ] i
went to uh
i went to a wedding that was at like a
you know whatever and
instead of having to cater like it was
catered but to save money they did
oh we'll just buy all the booze and then
we'll serve that rather than having the
third party sir
you run out so quick oh yeah so it's
like they're like oh we only got a half
of a james and you're like
it's like still light out well kind of
[ __ ] tie one on over here
i put 100 in the card let's go that's
that
it sounds good but that's like running
any party where you should just always
over buy
yeah or let somebody come in and say hey
it's on you like you're at a bar or a
restaurant you know you're at the venue
the venue has it dude a byob
wedding would be pretty fun that would
be different it would get sloppy
yeah i'd bring a cooler for sure yeah
rolling in with a [ __ ] party ball
yeah what about uh
the wedding gift i always give money how
much uh
i'll all right now i'm like venmoing
people i've done that for a wedding
people are
fine with that yeah all right let's do
this weird what's our last wedding you
went to
um i know what your question is to me
which is how much yes yes we want to get
something
here's the thing it depends on my
friendship with yeah
of course of course so on a wedding
where i feel as though i was a bubble
invite
like uh we kind of hope he says no yeah
like he
just made the cut i'll give if it's
just me uh i'll give 200 bucks okay
and if i have a date i'll give
double to 250 300 maybe okay
for the two of us um and that
but that's like that's a good point
because i won't get a plus one unless
i'm like closer to them
so what if it's like let's say a cousin
right a cousin that's like that the
invite is guaranteed
there's no you're not on the bubble it's
a i think 300 is a pretty
generous wedding gift for you and her or
just you
probably the two of you solid okay but
if it's like
if i'm in the wedding and it's a close
friend i've given 500 before
which is then then it's like this is
yeah yeah damn not bad but i also i
cause i don't want to be the friend that
like
even if because if even if everyone else
in that wedding party pays like a
thousand or something insane 500
nobody's gonna look at you like yeah wow
you're an [ __ ] 500 is like
a really good gift sure i also kind of
look at it as like if you're in the
wedding party it's like i'm already
sunking in for the [ __ ] talks i'm
sucking him for the [ __ ] not him he's
owned
it you should buy a tux my tux was less
than five hundred dollars
he's my best friend i'm gonna wear tux
to his [ __ ] wedding i'm not buying a
tux come on
true i feel like you guys are gonna wear
a bill you got the invite i'll tell you
that
dude there's not board shirts that fit
him he's like
she's n1 mesh shorts all day baby meet
me at the rucker
rocking it out and fours all right
you're a bigger guy
all right we got to get you out of here
um i mean
come on class kids class yeah kids class
all around me right
class in the booth what do you boys say
i i i'm stunned yeah i'm stunned
[ __ ] french piano hello you read the
resume though and you're ignoring some
of the nitty-gritty some of the
intangibles
and i'm not arguing that i'm trying to
sold cold coke once okay i like get over
it i love it this the
here are my here are my checks for class
speak french
plays classical piano passport at six
passport at six you've been in a
helicopter
didn't know what hair cuttery was and
you traffic cocaine so that's that's
all the boxes
yeah i mean you've definitely i'm not
it's also not a stamp of like oh
you're you know not you are impeachable
like you said but it's like
you have behaviors that you've done
trash nobody makes it no one's the
teflon
don right no one makes it 32 years
without you know dabbling in a dark
i wonder if i should have i mean some of
the some of the relationship
stuff maybe would have tipped the scales
a little bit farther yeah that happens
everybody's got you know you come from a
lineage of good stock
you had a good upbringing you know not
to say that you're a [ __ ]
you know you definitely got some
skeletons he's a good looking guy you
know
what about the blush did you have braces
when you were a kid only for a short
like 10 months i was lucky damn those
are just natural
well i had a huge overbite but then my
teeth moved very quickly back
into even his teeth his teeth are classy
yeah you know what i want to ask you how
do you in that environment when you were
selling
how did you deal with the people coming
in like late night looking for a second
bag and all that kind of stuff
all tweaked i mean they i didn't get
that that's that was the thing i was
i was selling to like a controlled group
of people
i wasn't answering a beeper and then
being like meet me around the block
we're gonna do a little joint you know
yeah but by the way those guys always
had really nice cars
oh yeah cocktails always got nice cars
like bmw 750s and like
nice legroom it's the 10 to eights as i
call them yeah
uh we got yeah we gotta wrap up we gotta
get francis allison gentlemen
thank you so much yeah you guys very
much this was so much fun is there
anything you want the folks out there to
know anything
coming up uh i'll be in indianapolis at
helium
on november 19th to the 21st
you can get tickets for that at
franciselles.com otherwise check out our
podcast oops
it's a lot of fun with we former guest
giulio gallarade one of our favorites
that's right
yeah kippy what do you got guys uh
cameron comedy on all social media
uh great review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube
uh yeah check us out thanks yes sir we
love you guys and we will see you
next week peace